alors c'est un moment très important et
c'est un moment de rencontre
attendu avec les deux responsables des
deux mouvements politiques qui forment
avec nous la
majorité euh c'est un moment amical
j'emploie le mot au sens le plus exa
possible parce que d'habitude l'amitié
en politique est une valeur
qu'on qu'on
voque sans être toujours absolument sûr
euh qu'on la respecte ou qu'elle
inspire le le fond de notre euh
réflexion ou de ou de nos affection mais
euh je veux dire simplement pour un
témoignage j'ai pas l'habitude de dire
le contraire de ce que je pense que avec
les deux responsables que nous allons
accueillir maintenant Stéphane séjourné
pour Renaissance que vous pouvez
[Applaudissements]
applaudir et Édouard Philippe comme
ancien chef de la majorité et
responsable et président de
[Applaudissements]
horizon nous avons des relations qui
répondent à une exigence de confiance et
de sincérité dont je peux dire que
en tout cas moi je la ressens comme
comme authentique comme réelle
euh et et que c'est nous nous parlons
chaque semaine au moins et souvent
plusieurs fois par semaine et cet
équilibre que nous avons atteint est un
équilibre précieux j'ajoute que euh tout
à l'heure toute cet après-midi est venu
partager nos notre rencontre Richard
Ferrand qui a été notre
[Applaudissements]
responsable dans tout le travail de
préparation que nous avons fait il y a
un an pour les élections législatives
Richard m'a dit qu'il devait repartir
parce que c'était l'anniversaire de son
fils je sais pas s'il est reparti ou pas
encore il est là approche-toi Richard
une seconde s'il te plaît une
seconde
[Applaudissements]
tu vas te mettre au premier
rang et je te préviens tu vas dire un
mot un mot voilà je veux dire simplement
que cette relation qui est une relation
de confiance et de sincérité euh c'est
aussi une relation et pour moi le mot a
beaucoup de sens de
corresponsabilité
euh chacun dans nos parcours dans nos
trajectoires
euh nous
avons exercé des responsabilités nous en
exerçons encore on a travaillé dans la
dans la première mandature du président
de la République on travaille maintenant
on a tous des amis au gouvernement que
je salue et à qui je dis notre amitié
mais nous nous sentons
coresponsable de l'avenir et c'est plus
important que tout ma vision personnelle
personne n obligé de la partager est
encore plus large que ça moi je crois
que nous sommes coresponsables de
l'avenir quel que soit notre engagement
c'est-à-dire pour moi
identiquement engagement politique
engagement syndical engagement
professionnel engagement dans les
communautés de pensé nous sommes
coresponsables de l'avenir même si nous
sommes en desésaccord entre nous mais à
forciorie bien sûr davantage encore
coresponsable puisque nous sommes
ensemble le la garantie de de la bonne
entente à l'intérieur de la majorité
est-ce que je puis rappeler simplement
pour ceux qui s'intéressent à la vie
politique que n'est pas
souvent que les formations politiques
qui forment une majorité s'entendent
entre elles c'est pas arrivé souvent
dans l'histoire et j'ai même des
souvenirs assez
précis d'époque un peu antérieur dans
lesquels cette amitié était doublée de
comment
dirais-je d'une compétition virile et
pas totalement correcte comme on dit
puisque c'est la Coupe du monde de rugby
donc je suis très heureux de vous dire
d'attester au fond devant vous que ça
n'est pas le cas de cette majorité ça
veut pas dire que nous sommes semblables
en tout ça veut pas dire que nous avons
surtout exactement les mêmes intuitions
les mêmes idées qu'il arrive assez
souvent même que nous puissions être
différents mais nous ne faisons pas de
nos différences une opposition
systématique et nous ne faisons pas de
nos différences une raison pour prendre
un avantage sur les autres pour enfoncer
les autres et se et se propulser
soi-même c'est un climat qui moi que je
trouve
moi de qualité humaine et civique et au
fond dans une maison comme celle-ci pour
qui la démocratie ça compte et pour qui
le civisme ça compte c'est une raison de
plus de les accueillir à avec plaisir et
chaleur et
[Applaudissements]
reconnaissance alors je vais quoi qu'il
m'it indiqué qu'il n'était absolument
pas question qu'il parle qui venait ici
par
amitié ben je vais lui dire que l'amitié
ça se prolonge et je donne la parole
pour les quelques minutes qu'il souhaite
à Richard Ferrand en
[Applaudissements]
disant en disant combien nous sommes
nombreux à regretter qu'il ne qu'il ne
puisse plus
exercer sa vigilance et son talent et
sa son esprit de de responsabilité au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale et je suis
donc content de suppler cette absence en
lui donnant la
[Applaudissements]
parole bien chers amis moi qui euh
comptez me tenir au fond de la salle
afin que mon départ prématuré ne soit
pas vécu comme un signal inconvenant je
ne pourrais donc pas échapper à votre
regard quand je verisagner Brest mais je
venais en tout cas avec joie aujourd'hui
en voisin et en ami comme c'est déjà
arrivé les années précédentes à Guidel
pour euh vous saluer toutes et tous qui
comme l'a rappelé François berou
constituer une des équipes de la
majorité alors c'est l'occasion
finalement il y a les trois pour le prix
d'un si je puux dire c'estàdire que l'on
peut à la fois saluer Édouard Philippe
président de d'horizon et Stéphane
séjourné qui est mon chef à
Renaissance parti dont je suis
adhérant je crois maintenant que je suis
loin parce que les électeurs ont choisi
de me rendre ma liberté et je dois vous
dire dire que quand je vois certains
débats je leur suis en réalité
infiniment reconnaissant de m'avoir
privé de participer à certains travaux
dans un certain climat et je veux saluer
la belle énergie la ténacité et le calme
des parlementaires de la majorité dont
je m'étonne parfois qu'il puissent
résister à des assaut qui étaient
jusque-là inconnus et qui ont pour but
de tout conflictualiser et donc de
porter atteinte à la démocratie et à la
démocratie parlementaire donc chapeau à
eux à tous les députés des trois groupes
de la
[Applaudissements]
majorité alors comme François m'a donné
la parole il m'a dit un mot mais je
pourrais tenir longtemps donc je vais
essayer de me réfrainer simplement vous
dire que ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
loin des yeux qu'on est pas près du cœur
pour ce qui me concerne je suis de ceux
qui estiment qu'on ne peut pas être et
avoir été mais que néanmoins les
engagements fondateurs qui ont conduit à
la fois l'élection du Président de la
République en 2017 puis à sa réélection
à l'élection d'une première majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale puis une majorité
relative en
2022 et bien tout cela évidemment j'y
reste profondément attaché et c'est donc
un ami et je tiens à ce mot comme
François un ami de la famille modem et
un ami des familles qui composent la
majorité que je suis heureux d'avoir pu
vous saluer et vous souhaiter de bons
travaux avec les trois présidents qui
vont nourrir le débat qui vient merci de
votre
[Applaudissements]
accueil merci Richard vous aurez compris
tous et toutes à quel point nous
apprécions sa présence et sa
personnalité et donc merci Richard je
vais maintenant vous demander
d'accueillir Stéphan séjourné qui est le
secrétaire général c'est ça de
renaissance et le président de notre
groupe au Parlement
[Applaudissements]
européen merci beaucoup François merci
d'avoir donné la parole à Richard parce
que je tenais à le dire aussi en
introduction Richard tu nous manques
beaucoup à Renaissance en particulier à
la majorité en général tu as su mener
les travaux à l'Assemblée nationale avec
une certaine distinction ce sont ces
présidents de l'Assemblée qui laisseront
leur marque leur empreinte leur style
aussi ça compte beaucoup en politique et
je voulais particulièrement te remercier
d'être là d'être présent dans nos
travaux y compris lors de nos bureaux
exécutifs au sein de renaissance je sais
que tu es présent mais tu n'es plus
actif mais en tout cas tu nous manques
beaucoup en politique et on a besoin de
l'expérience en tout cas des gens comme
Richard Ferrand et je tenais à le saluer
et merci encore de
[Applaudissements]
l'applaudir bon chers amis merci
beaucoup François de cette invitation
c'est toujours un honneur et y compris
je suis toujours très heureux de de
venir ici et c'est et c'est pas un mot
un mot
convenu
j'ai toujours le sentiment qu'il règne
une atmosphère
assez singulière à
Guidel à la fois studieuse conviviale
emprinte gravité dans certains moments
et ce moment où toutes les formations
politiques font leur université de
rentrée organise des débats sont aussi
des moments pour nous de rappeler un
certain nombre effectivement tu as
commencé à le faire de convergence
d'explication de pourquoi aussi la
majorité est ensemble d'assumer un
certain nombre de de de divergence mais
j'aiis peut-être commencer par là parce
que souvent on parle d'unité de
dépassement politique au sein de de mon
parti politique ce n'est pas une fin en
soi c'est la conséquence de de quelque
chose et vous avez ici des courants
politiques représentés entre moi
François Baayou Édouard Philippe qui
soit des socio-démocrates réformistes
qui soient des humanistes qui soient les
courants de pensée qui mettent la
liberté au cœur de leur projet politique
vous avez des courants de pensée qui ont
un point en commun c'est de toujours
regarder la complexité du monde et de
trouver une grille de lecture de la
complexité du monde avant de trouver des
solutions et je dis ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu rare en
politique c'est devenu rare au moment où
un certain nombre de partis politiques
de nationalistes de populistes cherch à
surfer sur les conséquences du dordre du
monde nous vous entendrez jamais une
intervention de François Baayou
d'Édouard Philippe ou de moi-même qui ne
commence pas par une grille de lecture
de la situation mondiale de
l'explication de pourquoi nous faisons
les choses et d'intégration à la fin de
notre sensibilité politique qu'elle soit
humaniste libérale progressiste
réformiste
social-démocrate et je pense que vous
avez de la chance de participer à un
parti politique ici au modem pour mes
militants à Renaissance qui a une
certaine culture à l'international à
l'Europe qui est capable aujourd'hui de
constater que la question climatique est
au cœur qu'elle engendera probablement
un désordre sur l'immigration que la
question la démographie qui parle
beaucoup à toutes nos formations
politique produira par conséquence des
faits internationaux et géopolitiques
majeurs qu'il faut se pré pé que
derrière il faut organiser nos
politiques publiques en fonction il faut
préparer nos opinions publiques à aussi
un certains bouleversement et c'est une
rigueur politique que nous partageons
quand nous regardons aujourd'hui les
autres formations politiques je le
disais entre surfer sur les peurs
organiser les craintes décourager les
uns et les autres d'avoir une réflexion
en profondeur ne plus partager la
contrainte Richard le disait avec y
compris le besoin de tout
conflictualiser on voit bien que il nous
manque des formations politiques
aujourd'hui dans la vie politique
française qui sont capables de faire cet
exercice à la fois d'organisation
politique de de structuration politique
mais avoir un raisonnement solide et je
crois aujourd'hui que c'est le cas et
vous avez participé ces derniers jours
et vous allez continuer à le faire
aujourd'hui et dimanche et je pense que
c'est sain pour à la fois nos minitants
et à la fois nos formations politiques
gardons cette rigueur je crois que c'est
peut-être le premier point sur lequel je
souhaitais insister parce que nous
partageons en tout cas cette cette
volonté vous dire que dans les en jeux
particuliers qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui l'instabilité que j'évoqué
les questions d'influence de la
démocratie de la démographie la remise
en cause des démocraties partout dans le
monde du suffrage universel des fois
même
en France on a on a une partielle je je
l'évoquais souvent dans nos réunions à
Renaissance nous avons une partielle
euh où la candidate du rassemblement
national euh et de LFI était en tête la
dernière fois partielle a eu a eu lieu
c'est notre candidate qui a gagné face à
quelqu'un de la France insoumise
réaction de la France insoumise vous
avez une députée du peuple qui a été
évincée alors que nous dans nos
formations politique on aurait dit on a
une députée qui a été batue les mots ont
un sens il y a pas des députés du peuple
et des députés il y a des députés du
peuple tout simplement et il y a des
élus battus mais personne n'est vincé
qu'est-ce que veut dire cette
formulation tout simplement c'est une
remise en cause de notre suffrage
collectif de notre suffrage universel de
notre mode de trancher nos différents en
démocratie derrière il faut être assez
conscient que il y a des attaques que
les mots ont un sens que ces sujets là
sont au cœur de notre problématique
aujourd'hui et qu'il faudra les défendre
et je sais que au Mouvement Démocrate
dans Mouvement démocrate il y a
démocrate je partage également ces
sujets là et le sujet de la démocratie
sera
probablement en tout cas pour pour nous
y compris à Ren Europe un point
essentiel dans la défense du modèle
démocratique européen des modèle de
démocratie libérale qui deviennent de
plus en plus en question et peut-être
même je sais pas si on avait des
statisti mais je crois même qu'ils sont
minoritaires aujourd'hui dans le
monde vous dire que à partir de cette
grille de lecture du monde on a agi
depuis 6 ans et je serais en faute si
aujourd'hui je mettrais pas un point
également à à revendiquer un certain
nombre de bilans sur le volet économique
il a fallu relancer l'économie pas comme
une fin en soi mais aussi pour financer
notre modèle aussi pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat pour créer des emplois
le chômage est au plus bas depuis 40 ans
les pays les plus attractifs d'Europe
c'est devenu la France la croissance
résiste la dette a même plus baissé ce
deè trimestre selon les ch de l'INC et
fait notoire le derpigle allemand cite
la France c'est l'Allemagne en mieux je
pense que ce sujet là est déjà un point
de bon bilan pour nous puisque si nos
collègues allemands le disent je crois
qu' il faut il faut pouvoir le relever
ensemble vous dire aussi qu'on a
quelques chantiers qui me semble
important d'abord il faudra garder le
cap sur le volet économique je le disais
mais sur le volet climatique parmi les d
règlements du monde le gouvernement a
annoncé une planification et on était
avec Édouard Philippe et François
baayrou à cette présentation par la
première ministre je tiens à dire et je
l'ai dit d'ailleurs la représentante du
parti des veres qui était avec
nous même les gouvernements qui intègre
aujourd'hui dans leur gouvernance dans
leur coalition
des partis verts en Europe n'ont pas
fait cet exercice de planification
d'organisation et c'est un exercice it
indit il faut que on le puisse le
défendre évidemment vous avez bien vu
que aujourd'hui la question de
l'environnement était redevenu un
clivage politique et je note que si
c'est devenu un clivage politique c'est
parce que nous avons aussi agi pendant
la première partie du quinina on nous
l'a souvent reproché Édouard le sait
très bien vous faites pas assez les
activistes ét très présent je vois
aujourd'hui que les deux fronts se
réouvrent j'ai envie de dire ceux qui
nous disent vous en faites trop ceux qui
nous disent aussi vous continuez à ne
pas en faire assez mais le en faire trop
est une nouveauté du deuxème quinena
preuve aussi que les choses ont bougé
que les lignes ont été transpersées sur
le volet sur le volet écologique et
qu'on a réussi réussi à faire au niveau
européen en tout cas la la transition
avec des des ambitions qui sont
radicales euh il faudra d'ailleurs voir
comment et c'est tout l'objet de la
planification comment on réussit à
emmener socialement économiquement euh
l'ensemble des Français et des Européens
dans cette transition qu'on a besoin qui
aura des répercussions internationales
géopolitiques qui aura des implications
sur l'immigration et nous avons
tellement besoin d'être le continent en
tête le continent qui soit le plus
vertueux et puis qui puisse aussi à un
moment donné donner l'exemple au reste
du monde 500 millions d'habitants 450
millions d'habitants l'Europe on est
petit par rapport au reste du monde mais
en tout cas si on a une législation la
plus vertueuse sur ces volets là je
pense qu'on aura une une capacité à
pouvoir exporter notre modèle à une
condition qui combine compétitivité et
justice sociale et c'est tout l'objet de
ces prochains mois que nous avons à à
faire au niveau européen d'ailleurs au
niveau national avec cette
planification un dernier point peut-être
aussi dans les enjeux je parlais de la
question démocratique on y est tous
inquiet et à juste tytre quand on
regarde les comparaisons
internationales je crois qu'on aura
besoin de réfléchir sur nos
institutions alors c'est un grand mot de
dire moderniser qu'on arrête déjà une
partie du vocabulaire mais qu'on passe à
l'action sur au niveau de la majorité
pour trouver un certain nombre de
solutions pour redonner un peu vie à la
démocratie il a une demande très forte
de nos concitoyens de plus participer à
la vie politique il faut pouvoir avoir
ces débats et ces discussion entre nous
moi je suis
convaincu que il faut que on
pérénise c'est toutes les forces
politique à l'Assemblée nationale je
suis convaincu qu'il faut une dose de
proportionnel je suis convaincu qu'il
faut retrouver des rites électoraux qui
nous permettre un peu d'avoir des débats
politiques je suis convaincu aussi que
il faut
moderniser peut-être le statut de l'élu
on en a beaucoup parlé depuis des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années mais
des générations ma génération
aujourd'hui ne veut plus s'investir en
politique ne veut plus s'investir en
politique on perd des compétences perd
des gens qui pourraient aujourd'hui agir
pour l'intérêt général et c'est la
responsabilité de nos partis politiques
c'est la responsabilité de renaissance
d'horizon du MoDem qui somme en
responsabilité d'aller aussi trouver
quelques propositions ici pour
réinvestir toute une génération qui
aujourd'hui préfère les causes à
l'intérêt général et à l'investissement
dans la vie politique et dans les partis
politiques et comme je vous le disais en
introduction au moins les partis
politiques nous donnent une
structuration une grille de lecture du
monde qui manque énormément aujourd'hui
à la société française et un certain
nombre de générations donc je je je je
pousse pour un mouvement en tout cas de
proposition communes sur les
institutions on pourra être efficace et
organiser les choses c'est un rôle que
les partis politiques pe peuvent avoir
qui doivent avoir d'ailleurs et j'en
serai aussi le garant du côté de
renaissance un dernier mot sur le combat
européen et puis je vais remercier
l'ensemble des collègues du MoDem qui
qui sont là qui depuis maintenant 4 ans
nous travaillons au sein du groupe renu
renw c'est 25 nationalités sans
parlementaires
un groupe une délégation française qui
est coprésidée par Valérie et Marie
piierre qui somm là qui sont là mais je
j'ai vu aussi l'ensemble des des
collègues qui étaient là j'ai vu
Laurence sur le sur la scène je voudrais
d'abord les remercier parce que François
tu parlais de camaraderie de
respect et je crois que ça a toujours
été le cas dans cette délégation
française et je pense que on a contribué
à notre petite échelle à ce que la
politique nationale aussi empagne le pas
sur ce que nous avons fait au niveau du
Parlement européen et donc je voudrais
vraiment vous remercier à la fin de bah
de votre
fidélité de vos compétences puisque vous
avez su faire bouger les lignes au
Parlement avec ce prisme et caractère
humaniste que vous revendiquez dans
toutes les politiques et je crois qu'on
a été très utile maintenant je vous mets
en garde par rapport aux élections qui
arrivent ne ne cédez pas à la
nationalisation du débat
européen on
a un débat européen tous les 5 ans et je
vous le dis je ne me laisserai pas voler
et on ne se laissera pas voler
collectivement le débat
européen je vois bien la tentation des
extrêmes à vouloir nationaliser cette
élection à partir très tôt dans
l'élection pour désigner des candidats
nous pousser à plus discuter du budget
de la France et des questions nationales
que des enjeux institutionnels et des
enjeux politiques que nous allons avoir
à
traverser pendant cette campagne des
européennes et nous aurons un débat sur
le sujet nous aurons un débat et j'en
serai également le garant le calendrier
sera fixé un peu plus loin et toujours
dans le respect et dans le dialogue
avant de faire des annonces précipitées
comme certains peuvent le faire dans
d'autres parti politique ils ont cette
j'ai envie de dire cette convenance de
d'être à la fois dans l'opposition
d'être à la tête d'un seul parti et donc
de pouvoir décider vite de pouvoir faire
l'élection européenne sur une élection
nationale nous on n pas cette option là
on on doit en tout cas nos électeurs ce
débat européen nous l'aurons je peux je
sais que je peux compter en tout cas sur
le modem et je sais que je pourrais
compter sur les parlementaires européens
sortant du MoDem qui ont été là jusqu'au
dernier moment et que je remercie encore
une fois merci François pour
cette opportunité de
m'exprimer tu seras évidemment le
bienvenu à Bordeaux aux universités
d'été du du de renaissance ainsi que
l'ensemble des des militants qui le
souhaitent longue vie à la majorité euh
et puis surtout que ces 4 ans puissent
être utiles pour les Français
c'est la ligne qui m'a été fixée aussi
par le Président de la République c'est
la ligne que nous devons tous avoir en
responsabilité et je trouve que cette
responsabilité depis cision a été très
bien exercée continuons ainsi
merci merci Stéphane et bien je suis
très heureux d'accueillir de vous
demander d'accueillir et de donner la
parole
au président de horizon édard
Philippe qui va maintenant s'adresser
[Applaudissements]
à mes amis c'est un grand c'est un grand
bonheur d'être à Guidel c'est grand
bonheur de retrouver le modem de
retrouver Marc et jeune VIè avec qui
j'ai eu l'honneur de
participer au gouvernement de la France
de retrouver Sara qui est venue à anger
je je je sais pas où elle est je la vois
pas de toute façon je vois rien il y a
trop de lumière
et G au moment où il est mort a dit
cette phrase extraordinaire que je cite
en allemand parce que c'est pas trop
compliqué il a dit mer l plus de lumière
bon je vais pas mourir en tout cas je
crois pas mais là il y en a trop
tout à l'heure il y avit un problème de
son là il y a un problème de lumière je
voudrais saluer Bruno milen s'il est
revenu mais je ne crois je ne crois pas
car j'ai bien vu qu'il partait au moment
où j'arrivais et j'aimerais que tous ses
amis lui disent que j'ai bien noté son
départ au moment où
j'arrivais je voudrais remercier mode
pour son accueil saluer Patrick Mignola
que je n'ai pas encore vu mais que
j'espère pouvoir croiser tout à l'heure
remercier évidemment et
saluer Richard Ferrand qui nous a quitté
pour Brest et Stéphane séjourné que je
suis heureux de retrouver ici remercier
Jean-Paul matthi qui a créé une
connexion Corse à la tête de d'un binôme
modem horizon que je recommande vivement
de garder à
l'œil et puis remercier évidemment
François et lui dire combien je suis
heureux d'être
ici tout à l'heure avec une élégance qui
n'appartient qu'à lui il a indiqué que
il n'avait pas été totalement courant
dans l'histoire de la politique
française que des formations politiques
qui constituaient une majorité puissent
continuer à s'entendre
bien il faut bien reconnaître que le
béarne et la Normandie ne sont pas des
terres géographiquement
proches mais je dois dire que nous avons
entamé depuis maintenant plusieurs
années et que nous approfondissons avec
le temps avec François une conversation
euh fait de litot et
d'antirase lesquels manifestement sont
également utilisé dans le béarne et en
Normandie et ces conversations
euh don je dois dire qu'elles me charme
euh elles m'ont permis d'apprendre un
certain nombre de choses et je voudrais
vous donner quelques quelques
enseignements que cette conversation
avec François ont permis de retirer d'
m'ont permis de retirer ma veste et ma
cravate puisque je suis arrivé avec une
veste et une cravate et François m'a dit
tiens tu as mis une cravate et une
veste j'ai donc enlever la cravate et la
veste comprenant bien qu'il y avait un
sujet mais plus sérieusement je retiens
de ces conversations je peux le dire
François parce que ce sont des phrases
que tu as déjà prononcé en public
deux deux éléments de sagesse deux
éléments de sagesse euh qui me font
songer depuis que tu me les as enseigné
et dont j'essaie de m'inspirer le
premier élément de sagesse c'est quelque
chose que tu m'as appris pendant que
nous discutions sur l'organisation des
législatives tu m'as dit le meilleur
moment pour dire non c'est le
premier c'est vachement
intelligent c'est extrêmement
intelligent et j'ai tout de suite saisi
qu'il y avait quelque chose
d'intelligent quand François l'a dit
mais maintenant 1 an après je dois dire
que c'est vraiment très intelligent
la deuxième chose et c'est aussi un
élément de sagesse c'est on est toujours
plus fort en étant soi-même et c'est
très juste et c'est très juste
euh et je suis donc heureux de pouvoir
rendre à César ce qui est à François et
et et lui dire que de ces conversations
je ne tire pas simplement le partage
d'une analyse politique le la discussion
d'une stratégie l'élaboration même
parfois d'une tactique je retiens aussi
des éléments de sagesse de culture qui
compte pour moi et je veux t'en
remercier
[Applaudissements]
alors lors de la rentrée parlementaire
du parti horizon qui s'est tenu à anger
où l'ami Bruno milienne représentait le
modemme c'est pour ça que je le je le
van maintenant
euh j'ai beaucoup évoqué les questions
relatives à à l'Europe et j'ai aussi
parlé d'un d'un étau dont nos
concitoyens sentaient qu'il était en
train de se refermer sur leur vie et sur
leur perspective
je je je voudrais dire un petit peu plus
de de mots si vous le voulez bien sur
cet ét et et et concentrer mon propos
relatif à cet ét sur une question
particulière qui est la question du
logement cet étau il nous il nous sert
tous nous voyons tout ce qu'il est en
train de se refermer sur nous c'est les
taux de l'inflation une nourriture qui
coûte plus cher une essence qui coûte
plus cher une électricité qui coûte plus
cher une vie qui coûte plus cher et le
sentiment pas du un sentiment d'ailleurs
c'est la réalité partagée par nos
concitoyens
que travailler ne permet pas de
desserrer les mâchoires de cet étau
c'est les taux des prix mais c'est aussi
les taux des
loyers en
2017 les études montrent que les ménages
consacrés globalement alors évidemment
c'est une moyenne moyennes sont à la
fois utiles à connaître et incomplète
par nature mais les études montrent que
les ménages consacrés environ un peu
moins de 20 % de leur revenus à leur
logement on est aujourd'hui à environ 30
% la
proportion des revenus consacrés au
logement est croissante et devient un
problème politique social économique
humain et je le dirai même vous verrez
pourquoi
démocratique l'accès au logement est
devenu critique pour les étudiant
délicat pour les jeunes actifs en vérité
pénible pour tout le monde donnant le
sentiment que progressivement nos
concitoyens sont exclus de la propriété
donnant le sentiment non pas le
sentiment mais indiquant que lorsque
l'on est un Français gagnant sa vie au
salaire médiant ce qui est pas mal on ne
peut plus accéder sauf à pouvoir
bénéficier à un moment donné d'un apport
en capital lié notamment à un héritage à
un appartement dans une grande ville
euh imaginez qu'en France il soit
difficile pour un de nos concitoyens au
salaire médian d'acheter sans héritage
un appartement dans une grande ville
est un constat qui devrait nous saisir
devant l'ampleur des conséquences qu'il
entraîne j'ai cité à anger je le recite
bien volontiers aujourd'hui un article
un court article que je vous encourage
vivement àer trouver
d'un un auteur qui s'appelle Antoine
Fouchet qui j'ai travaillé parce qu'il a
été pendant quelques temps vous vous en
souvenez peut-être les amis le directeur
de cabinet euh de la ministre du Travail
et Antoine Foucher écrit un article qui
s'appelle la fin du travail la fin de la
société du travail pas pas du tout sur
le thème la société du travail est en
train de disparaître dans une société du
divertissement ce qu'on lisait assez
volontiers dans les années 70 en 80
quand on parlait de la société du
divertissement pas non plus d'ailleurs
parce que il n'aimerait plus le travail
ou qui ne respecteraiit plus le travail
c'est peut-être le cas pour certains
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit le cas
pour la majorité des Français Antoine
Fouchet dit nous vivons la fin de la
société du travail parce que travailler
sérieusement ne permet plus de modifier
son niveau de vie et il montre que pour
quelqu'un qui est au salaire médian et
qui euh dans les années 50 à 70
travaillait de façon lionire au salaire
médian l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
annuel de l'ordre de 4 à 6 % permettait
de doubler son niveau de vie en environ
15 ans et donc travailler sans changer
de métier nécessairement mais
progressivement permettez de S dans son
niveau de vie dans son pouvoir d'achat à
partir des années 70 et jusqu'aux années
à partir des années 80 jusqu'aux années
2010 cette évolution ne s'est plus fait
sur 15 ans doublement du pouvoir d'achat
ou du niveau de vie mais sur 40 ans ça
voulait dire qu'une vie de travail
permettait de s'élever mais il fallait
une vie de travail on constate
aujourd'hui avec les évolutions que vous
connaissez tous qu'il faudrait pour
bénéficier de ce mouvement travailler 70
ans et même ceux qui comme moi pensent
qu'il va falloir travailler plus
longtemps pour financer les retraites
savent que 70 ans de travail ça n'existe
pas dans une ville ça n'existe pas et on
a donc ce constat qui est terrible qui
est terrible lorsque on pense que le
travail est un élément de lien social
d'épanouissement et ou nécessité nous
avons ce constat terrible qu'une vie de
travail ne suffit plus à changer la
donne s'agissant d'un individu ou d'un
ménage c'est ça cette fin de la société
du travail et cette fin de la société du
travail elle est liée notamment à
l'évolution des logements à l'évolution
de la politique du logement nous allons
vivre une séquence explosive les amis
nous sommes déjà entrés dedans et on on
le sent on en parle à mon avis pas
suffisamment peut-être pas assez en tout
cas mais nous allons vivre une séquence
explosive liée à la crise du logement
cette crise nous la voyons venir elle
est là elle a trois causes qui sont
faciles à identifier une crise de la
construction une crise du marché de
l'offre locative une crise de la demande
toutes les trois ensemble intermél se
conjuguant et
s'empirant les unes les autres si j'ose
dire la crise de la construction c'est
lié à la difficulté de l'accès au
fonciers c'est lié au prix des matières
c'est lié aux normes qui rendre toujours
plus cher la construction alors même que
dès 2017 nous avions voulu simplifier
des normes et rendre la construction
moins cher la vérité c'est que le
phénomène que nous constatons est d'une
violence plus exactement d'uneune
solidité d'une fermet
qui fait que nous nous enfonçons dans
une crise de la construction la crise de
l'offre locative c'estàd la crise de
l'accès au marché de la location qui est
rendu malheureusement possible par la
conjugaison de beaucoup de mesures qui
sont
toutes le produit
de tout le produit d'une analyse de la
situation qui voudrait améliorer les
choses c'est la conjonction de Airbnb du
diagnostic de performance énergétique du
permis de louer du blocage de de louyer
de l'augmentation des taxes foncières
nous rendons le marché de l'offre
locative la possibilité d'obtenir un
logement de louer un logement de plus en
plus compliqué nous sommes en train de
stresser le marché de l'offre locative
il est en train de se contracter quand
il se contracte il crée une crise très
forte pour ceux qui ont besoin de
trouver un bien sur le marché locatif
enfin la crise de la demande et ben
c'est la crise liée à la hausse des taux
d'intérêts elle est mécanique et elle
est violente vous connaissez cette
statistique qui parle d'elle-même la
moitié des demandes de crédit
lié à l'achat d'un appartement ou d'une
maison sont refusés la moitié est refusé
par par les banques ça veut dire que on
a la crise de la construction la crise
du marché locatif et la crise de la
demande en même temps si j'ose dire
alors que
faire faut toujours se demander que
faire c'est ce que faisait Lénine que
faire et ça me fait toujours du bien de
citer Lénine à Guidel devant le
Moder d'abord la première chose mes
amis
je crois que nous devons arrêter de
stresser le marché
locatif si nous voulons régler une
partie de la solution nous avons
impérativement besoin de desserrer les
taux sur le marché locatif qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut pas dire des choses
faciles ça veut dire des choses dont il
faut bien mesurer ce qu'ell représente
premier point
Airbnb je suis certain qu'ici moi le
premier vous avez parfois
utiliséirbnb pour mettre en location
c'est pas mon cas mais pour utiliser
l'instrument pour trouver une
location c'est formidable ça permet
rapidement de trouver une alternative à
l'offre hôéière euh et certains
utilisent tellement l'instrument qu'ils
peuvent avoir une rémunération qui vient
compléter des revenus qui est utile il
ne s'agit pas de critiquer l'utilisation
d'Herbin mais la vérité vraie c'est que
dans toute une série de zones notamment
les zones tendu les zones touristiques
les zones littorales le développement
tellement rapide d'Airbnb crée un
phénomène éviction des voisins au profit
des touristes créer un phénomène qui
interdit d'avoir accès à un marché
locatif puisque les propriétaires se
disent qu'ils gagneront autant voir plus
avec moins de contrainte lié au
dégagement d'un éventuel locataire qui
ne pait pas grâce au marché grâce à
Airbnb et donc ce produit se développe
et il ne s'agit pas encore une fois de
mettre en cause ceux qui l'utilise il
s'agit de dire que l'utilisation qui en
est faite est en train de faire peser
une pression bien trop considérable et
de susciter des effets bien trop pervers
pour le marché de l'offre locative
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on a fait déjà des
choses aujourd'hui on ne peut pas mettre
en location sur RBI un bien dans un
certain nombre de zone plus de 120 jours
par an vous avez des des endroits
Amsterdam Londres où on a descendu cette
limite à 90 ou à 60 jours vous avez même
des endroits aux États-Unis où on
interdit la location d'un bien moins de
30 jours d'affilé c'est une logique un
peu différente on fait en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de location à la semaine ou
de location au weekend je vous fais
observer Mesdames et Messieurs que j'ai
cité Amsterdam Londres et New York qui
sont trois villes à l'évidence attaché à
à à ne pas s'inscrire dans une logique
libérale voyez Amsterdam Londres et New
York bah la vérité c'est que ces villes
touristiques comme beaucoup d'autres
villes en France ont compris la
nécessité de la régulation et ont
compris la nécessité d'éviter l'éviction
complète de nos concitoyens des
centre-villees et notez bien Mesdames et
Messieurs que c'est d'autant plus
indispensable que nous sommes sinon en
train de développer un discours
parfaitement schizophrène à l'égard de
nos concitoyens en leur disant attention
l'étalement urbain très mauvais il faut
revenir vivre dans les villes ce que je
crois profondément dans le même temps on
leur explique oui mais vous trouverez
pas d'appartement parce que ils vont
être réservés à des locations très
brèves très rémunératrice qui ne vous
intéresse pas qui ne vous concerne pas
il y a là quelque chose qui est une
bombe qui est une bombe sociale qui est
une bombe urbaine si j'ose dire qu'il
faut régler premier sujet deuxème sujet
encore plus délicat et peut-être la
prudence
devrait m'inciter à ne pas en parler
mais quand même je vais le faire non
mais quand même je vais le
faire le diagnostique de
performance énergétique d PEE là aussi
on parle d'un sentiment qui n'est pas un
sentiment qui est une analyse juste sur
le fait que les passoirs thermiques sont
un problème énergétique un problème
environnemental et un problème sociale
et la majorité la majorité la précédente
majorité à penser un système qui
consiste à dire nous allons devoir faire
en sorte de contraindre les
propriétaires à faire des travaux qui
permettront d'éviter ces passoirs
terermiques et une de ces un de ces
éléments ça va être de dire à partir
d'une certaine date
2025 les appartements qui sont classés
en G c'est-à-dire la plus piètre
performance ne pourront plus être remis
à la location devront sortir du marché
aussi longtemps qu'ils n'auront pas fait
l'objet de
travaux idée que
j'entends et que je peux comprendre sur
le plan théorique et que je peux dont je
vois très bien l'intérêt sur le plan
politique mais il se trouve que par
ailleurs je suis maire du Havre d'une
ville assez pauvre ou en tout cas dans
laquelle il y a beaucoup de quartiers de
très grande pauvreté et qu'est-ce que
j'observe j'observe que dans un certain
nombre de ces
quartiers sortir du marché de la
location des
appartements classé en G c'est
mécaniquement réduire l'offre locative
pour les plus modestes et évidemment
pour les plus modestes ce qui veut dire
que ceux qui vont d'abord payer le prix
de cette mesure ce ne seront pas les
gens qui ont les moyens de faire des
travaux chez eux ou qui sont
propriétaires d'un logement ce seront
ceux qui ont besoin d'accéder à des
logements en effet peu chers en effet
probablement passoir thermique sur le
marché locatif nous sommes en train et
c'est le fruit d'excellent sentiment que
je ne cherche pas encore à mettre en
cause nous sommes en train de
créer une impasse pour les plus modestes
je l'ai dit au début de l'année parce
qu'il m'a semblé que c'est ce que je
voyais au Arre et que c'est ce qu'il
fallait dire et juste après l'avoir
écrit même dans un dans un hebdomadaire
le ministre du Logement de l'époque m'a
appelé en me disant Édouard tu peux pas
dire ça la transition écologique c'est
vraiment important et il avait raison la
transition écologique c'est vraiment
important mais je peux dire ça je peux
dire ça parce que je crois que c'est
vrai et je vois bien qu'un certain
nombre de gens commencent à s'en rendre
compte et je vois bien que on est gêné
parce que personne ne veut donner le
sentiment et surtout personne ne veut
donner prise à l'idée que il ne faudrait
pas aller vite et être ambitieux en
matière de transition écologique mais
disons que l'expérience m'a laissé
comprendre qu'un très bon dispositif
intellectuel que je peux parfaitement
approuver lorsque ces implications sont
toujours toujours dirigées s'agissant de
leurs effets les plus difficiles sur les
plus modestes à peu de chance de passer
dans notre population et à peu de chance
même d'une certaine façon de produire
les effets qui sont attendus donc je le
dis il faut déstresser le marché locatif
sans rien renoncer à l'ambition
écologique qui est la nôtre et qui est
absolument impérative mais nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas voir ce sujet qui
arrive et qui arrive vite 2025 c'est
demain et les propriétaires les
locataires ils sont obligés de voir loin
pour prendre des décision troisème chose
nous devons changer la logique changer
la logique de la politique du logement
savez-vous Mesdames et Messieurs que la
politique du logement c'est près de 40
milliards par an beaucoup d'argent 40
milliards par
an alors quand on dit qu'il faut changer
la politique du logement en général vous
avez toujours quelqu'un en général c'est
un constructeur ou un promoteur bref
quelqu'un du secteur qui vous dit CER
c'est 40 milliards de dépenses par an
mais c'est 96 milliards de recettes donc
faites attention si vous touchez aux
milliards de dépenses vous allez
diminuer les montants de recette c'est
vrai mais on pourrait aussi imaginer
qu'un système qui fonctionne bien
permettrait d'augmenter les recettes on
pourrait même imaginer qu'un système qui
fonctionne bien permettrait de baisser
les dépenses tout en conservant les
recettes on pourrait quand même se dire
qu'un système qui fonctionne avec 1,3 %
du PIB comme c'est le cas s'agissant de
la politique du logement en France nous
permettrait d'obtenir des résultats un
peu meilleurs qu'à l'étranger où on nous
consacre que 0,5 % du PIB dans les pays
comparables sur la politique du logement
bah pas du tout les amis pas du tout
nous n'avons pas de très bons résultats
et pourtant nous y consacrons beaucoup
d'argent il faut donc changer la logique
changer la logique ça peut vouloir dire
essayer de faire en sorte par exle
exemple je le dis devant François donc
je sais qu'il est attaché à cette
question s'agissant d'un pays
extrêmement d'un état extrêmement
endetté ça peut peut-être vouloir dire
quitte à financer une partie de la
politique du logement autant veiller à
ce que les seuls qui fassent du capital
ne soi pas nécessairement d'autres que
l'état de façon à ce qu'une partie du
financement des biens puisse revenir
s'agissant du désendettement à l'état
pour que s'agissant de la valorisation
du capital fait à l'état pour qu'il
puisse se désendetter il y a là un
changement de logique à opérer et la
vérité c'est que je pense que le secteur
du du logement n'y est pas totalement
favorable mais je suis certain que si on
explique les mérites aux Français ils
peuvent entendre l'intérêt de ce
changement de logique deuxième chose
nous devons développer les foncières
publiques et privé pour faire en sorte
que le capital ne soit pas inactif mais
au contraire qu'il puisse tourner et que
nous puissions retrouver des capacités
d'investissement pour rénover car c'est
la trème priorité nous devons moins
préoccuper de construire que de rénover
l'existant de transformer l'existant les
friches commerciales les bâtiments
conçus pour faire du logement et qui en
vérité demain ne seront plus des
logements nous devons rénover l'ancien
et nous devons donc sortir de cette
logique de la construction faudra
toujours construire bien entendu mais il
faut mettre l'accent sur autre chose
rénover plutôt que construire densifier
plutôt que étaler c'est un autre
impératif un impératif urbain c'est un
impératif humubain nous devons densifier
nos
villes il n'y aura pas de sujet si on
veut éviter si on veut éviter d'utiliser
des terres agricoles ou des espaces
naturels si on veut éviter d'étaler
tellement nos agglomérations de façon à
ce que nous coupions toutes les
interactions sociales et nous savons
bien ce que ça veut dire couper les
interactions sociales sur un territoire
c'est terrible et bien nous devons
redonner non pas interdire mais redonner
envie à nos concitoyens de vivre en
ville je vous parle de ça rapidement
mesdames et messieurs et j'ai bien
conscience que parler de la politique de
logement ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
s'exposer à un enthousiasme considérable
c'est technique c'est même souvent
incpréhensible en tout cas pour moi et
d'ailleurs je doute pas qu'il un certain
nombre de commentateurs qui diront
manifestement j'ai pas
compris si si vous
verrez mais je vous le dis il n'y a
aucune
hypothèse aucune hypothèse que nous
régli les questions de pouvoir
d'achat de perspective de société du
travail si nous ne redonnons pas un peu
de marge de manœuvre et si nous ne
décerons pas les taux du logement en
France
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui et je vais terminer par
cette remarque qui n'est pas plus gay
qui n'est pas plus joyeuse mais qui me
semble tout aussi
vraie
il n'y a pas de démocratie qui subsiste
durablement à une érosion continue du
pouvoir d'achat des classes moyennes ça
n'existe pas lorsque le pouvoir d'achat
des classes moyennes diminue
progressivement de façon continue brutal
dans le temps la démocratie n'y résiste
pas la promesse démocratique ça n'est
pas simplement un
processus ça n pas simplement une
méthode de délibération qui est très
importante la promesse démocratique
c'est aussi que nous créion n CROUS
CR nous
organisions une société ouverte une
société dans laquelle nous pouvons nous
épanouir individuellement et nous élever
collectivement
et c'éta une des promesses probablement
la plus important la plus judicieuse du
président de la République en 2017 qui
fait que j'ai été fier et heureux d'être
son premier ministre pendant 3 ans
mais si le pouvoir d'achat des classes
moyennes continue à stagner si même
demain il continue à diminuer pour
certains alors je vous le dis la
démocratie n'y résistera pas et c'est
donc pour cela que vous parlez de
politique du logement cert au sujet
technique est en réalité un élément de
la crise démocratique que nous vivons or
ici au modem on est attaché à la
démocratie viscéralement attaché à la
démocratie intellectuellement
humainement vcéralement attaché à la
démocratie et bien mon sentiment c'est
que parmi tous les autres grands sujets
qui doivent faire vivre la démocratie et
auxquel nous devons nous attaquer pour
résoudre les problèmes de la démocratie
actuelle il y a cette question du
pouvoir d'achat et il y a cette question
du logement j'étais heureux de vous le
dire merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup je voudrais dire merci à Stan s
journé et à Édouard Philippe et à
Richard Ferrand s'il était encore là
pour deux raisons
principales la première c'est que il
n'aura pas échappé aux
observateurs que vous êtes aussi acteur
et observateur et à ceux qui ont partagé
ces moments avec nous en tant
qu'observateur pur il n'aura pas échappé
que
le le ton le climat de
notre relation de responsabilité euh est
euh assez profond pour que nous
puissions envisager l'avenir ensemble
l'avenir des élections européennes et
l'avenir des autres échéances
électorales qui viendront et il n'aura
pas échappé à tout le monde
que ce climat particulier dont nous
avons parler tous les trois euh il
éclaire d'une manière
révélatrice les mois de débat qui
viennent devant nous et de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat au
Parlement européen ce n'est pas rien de
s'entendre ça paraît évident mais
s'entendre d'habitude ça a deux
significations la première de ces
significations c'est que les uns veulent
prendre le pas sur les
autres c'est l'entente impérialiste on
va dire ça comme ça soumets-toi et on
s'entendra très bien ou bien c'est dans
d'autres cas le sentiment que les
différences deviennent inéluctablement
des divergences et que ces divergences
portent atteinte à la solidité de
l'ensemble nous avons échappé à ces deux
fatalités enfin je crois que tout le
monde le
sentira si c'était pas le cas vous
auriez senti le contraire sans beaucoup
de difficultés c'est arrivé dans notre
histoire de manière suffisamment
explicite ça c'est la première raison et
la deuxième raison c'est que cette
manière de de se
respecter de se prendre en
considération de se reconnaître nous
permet d'aborder les sujets les plus
profonds que nous avons devant nous et
il va y en avoir beaucoup toute la
journée ont été aigrené à cette tribune
les grands enjeux de société en vérité
de
civilisation on dit toujours enjeux de
société oui pas seulement c'est que ce
que nous
portons dépasse de très loin nos intérêt
immédiat ce que nous faisons c'est bâtir
ensemble des générations à venir si nous
réussissons peut tout à
fait conclure déduire de la situation
aujourd'hui que nous allons laisser aux
générations que nous représentons
aujourd'hui et qui vont s'affirmer
demain on va leur laisser un monde
invivable un monde d'impasse
successiv et on pourrait très bien
aigrener la liste de ces impasses
impasse climatique impasse financière
impasse politique impasse géopolitique
un vous voyez bien le la l'incroyable
liste des risques que nous avons devant
nous ma conviction profonde et que la
vie démocratique du pays doit prendre en
charge ces risques là et dépassant notre
le périmètre de notre
majorité je crois assez bien
équilibré dépassant ce périmètre ce que
je crois profond
c'est
que quelle que soit la situation
politique je l'ai dit syndicale et je
l'ai dit professionnel et je l'ai dit de
communauté de
pensée de chacun des intervenants nous
devons prendre cela en charge tous
ensemble pas seulement dans le monde
politique et pas seulement dans la
majorité mais le
pays je crois profondément alors pour
ceux qui sont là vous m'avez entendu
dire ça 100 fois je crois profondément
que la démocratie consiste à considérer
les citoyens comme coresponsable de
l'avenir avec
vous la démocratie ça consiste à prendre
au sérieux l'idée que ceux qui vous
élisent sont des décideurs et pas
seulement une fois tous les 5 ans tous
les 4 ans parce que le poids des
opinions publiques est
tel dans la formation de la décision
dans l'équilibre des gouvernants dans
leur dans l'URA qui leur permettent de
vivre le poids de l'opinion publique est
tel que s'il n'y a pas cette
compréhension réciproque ou cette
compréhension partagée alors vous êtes
dans l'affrontement et si vous êtes dans
l'affrontement vous pouvez plus
gouverner pardon de dire ça sous cette
forme on a eu des débats sur ce sur ce
sujet moi je crois que euh
gouverner c'est gouverner pas seulement
au nom du peuple pour une un temps
défini c'est gouverner avec le
peuple et si nous n'arrivons pas à faire
cela alors Édouard précisément je crois
que la démocratie n'y résistera
pas parce que vous ne pouvez plus
affronter le sentiment d'un
peuple parce que ça devient très vite
spectaculaire violent j'ai souvent dit
pris cet exemple autrefois du temps de
clémenau il y avait des mouvements dans
l'opinion publique vous envoyez la
police avec les pèlerines roulées il
matraquaient les les types ils ont tuer
quelques-uns pas mal même parfois ça
faisait pas d'émotion parce que personne
le voyait il y avait des compesrendus
dans les journaux mais le le la prose
écrite n'est pas suffisante pour
provoquer l'émotion aujourd'hui vous
avez une jeune fille de 16 ans qui a
l'arcade sourcilière
ouverte de laquelle le le sang coule sur
son visage prise en gros plan à la
télévision et bien l'émotion populaire
est telle que vous ne pouvez plus
résister à cela ça nous impose de
changer complètement nos méthodes de
gouvernement on y est
pas parce que les pouvoirs en général
croient que c'est comme
autrefois les pouvoirs en général
croient que bon il suffit de tenir
bon c'était un débat qu'on a eu dans la
vie politique française
c'était la vision de Madame Sacher
elle pensait que si on tenait bon s'il y
avait quelques mineurs qui mouraient de
grève de la fin c'était pas très
grave elle a tenu bon
grâce à l'invention de la guerre des
malowin s'il avait pas eu la guerre elle
était liquidée déjà à cette époque là
aujourd'hui autant de des écrans hyper
présents et des réseaux
sociaux pour moi ça n'est pas
concevable il faut donc faire un
effort
puissant qui va mettre en cause nos
manières d'être pour
inventer le le principe tion des
citoyens aux
décisions politiques de première
importance ça demande du respect ça
demande de l'intelligence collective ça
demande de la générosité pour partager
l'information parce que quand on est au
pouvoir et qu'on a des informations qui
vous font prendre des décisions on n pas
envie de les partager c'est bizarre
c'est comme ça parce que tout le monde
comprend que l'information c'est le
pouvoir aussi et ça demande or cet
effort n'est condu nulle part dans le
monde il nous revient donc d'être c'est
pas la première fois dans l'histoire en
première ligne de cette réinvention de
la démocratie que je crois que je crois
essentiel et que je crois que nous
croyons tous ensemble essentiel merci à
Stéphane et merci à Édouard Philippe
d'être venu avec
nous